all right well welcome to session 18 of
classic metal class uh we're joined here
by scott chirulli as ever who's going to
be contributing a lot of
music technology and dynamics and other
things uh connected when it comes to
power ballads which are
our topic here today we're also joined
by birthday boy mark smith who is a
regular
uh in in attending this and so you know
he's spending his birthday evening with
us which is very cool
and uh you know who doesn't like power
ballots right uh i mean some people
might claim that they don't but maybe
there's like a secret soft spot in all
of us
for these
arguably you know over the top schmaltzy
things that some people want to say
aren't metal but as we're going to talk
about even some thrash bands have done
power ballads so
you know we're going to try to avoid
being judgey here and talk more about
the history and
musical aspects and and maybe you know
geek out a bit about some of our
favorite
power ballads as well so scott thanks
for for joining as as always and uh mark
glad you could be here too and hope
everybody else finds this quite
interesting so you know actually let's
before we jump into like talking about
definitions or anything like that let's
just reminisce a little bit because
scott and i
are both you know um
metal heads from
childhood and teenage years and we came
up during the era of the power bill
so
you know um i remember
sometimes being a little conflicted
about it because i'm i'm more of a
what dina weinstein who will talk about
what would call a traditional heavy
heavy metal guy and less into the you
know what she calls light or pop or
or um
you know glam metal um and yet at the
same time there were bands that were
like kind of straddling the fence on
that you think about rat you know who
i'm wearing a shirt from right now
motley crew
wasp you know a lot of these la bands
were kind of
straddling both fences and there are
things that sound like power ballads
coming from some of the great british
bands and then you know one of the heavy
bands that are also masters of the power
ballad are the scorpions
i mean
what's what's your think back you know
you'd hear these songs
power ballads they they get us
emotionally did they do they grip you
well the first one i really uh
remember
this may not be the first one i heard
but you know um
uh you know scorpions um still loving
you
and
um
i guess i didn't think of it as a power
ballot i mean when did that come out was
i 12 00
it would have been 84 right on love at
first sting
so more so yeah yeah and then worldwide
live they did it and um
there was something different about it
so like but for that i i just remember
that being the first one that really
struck me that was like
the slow back beat but still you know a
hard-hitting snare and and then the big
chorus and then the epic guitar solo at
the end you know this yeah nintendo and
um
i don't know what i i don't know if i
called it a ballad or what i would have
called it at the time
but the other memory i have is
a little later on with the macaulay
shanker group they had that
they had that album save yourself
and i got it and um i was playing it i
don't think my mom liked it at all but
then my brother
my they had a hit with that song any
time which is that a power balance
yeah
and
you know it was on the radio my brother
said he said you know mom actually
really likes that song
and so that's interesting right so like
the save yourself the the fast drum
beats up but she did like the power
balance yeah and so that was kind of
like i guess that would be the
the the test right there you know would
my mom like this that she would like
this and it was always the power balance
like she did like the scorpions one but
she didn't like big city nights or yeah
at home or
you know now that i think about it so
power ballads another thing that you
could say about them and there's also
power ballads that are not metal but
they um the metal ones it gave them a
different
access you know we're going to talk
about like you know um radio play and
stuff like that so but i think at dances
too
or even just sort of random hearing
stuff you know people who wouldn't be
into metal as such could get into
metal power ballads in part because they
were straddling
um
musical genres because there's not just
metal power ballads there's hard rock
power ballads there's even soft rock
power right that's right so
yeah
so mark says scorpion ballads made up a
disproportionate amount of my guitar
repertoire when i was younger they were
such a guilty pleasure i always remember
those songs fondly because they're
intimately tied to that that time in my
life and and i think so there's two
things i want to sort of riff on with
that i i think that
for for many of us
these
emotionally constructed songs do tie in
with particular
eras of our our life but um this is
where i want to turn it over to you
scott as a musician as a somebody who
was you know
starting to
have ideas about uh what you were doing
with the guitar while you're actually
hearing this um you have a different
experience in that respect than i do
because i would just listen to the stuff
and i'd be like oh yeah this is this is
good good songs right
you
have the capacity to like say well maybe
i'll learn this song or maybe this solo
has something to teach me so
early on like in your teens when power
ballads were coming out were
did they speak to you musically
oh huge um
um
you know as a guitar player a funny
memory i have
um i used to take guitar lessons at the
store
and uh upstairs were all the music rooms
so there was like maybe three guitar
teachers a piano teacher yeah all of us
with guitars would be like outside on
the bench like waiting
and we would all kind of be silently
showing off the new riffs we learned
right you know some people play smoke on
the water some kid but i remember one
kid played the intro to still loving you
correctly
like
oh wow you know and we got really
excited because that was like not a
hard-hitting thing it was like
included like some arpeggiations of some
chord shapes you weren't familiar with
and yeah
i remember that he became the cool one
because i was doing like rocky like a
hurricane
and then he would just but we all did it
quiet until like everybody's like hey
can you can you show me that
and so um
well even like i don't know if we would
call like uh foolin
by uh def leppard a powerball because it
just gets to heavy rock but yeah yeah
that beginning acoustic part was like uh
that was almost cooler to learn when i
was younger because i was like we'd a
power chord we can make sense of but i
think that is a power ballad actually
now that i i'm sort of like playing it
in my head
it does have uh some of the components
that we're looking for like the the
first part of it is pretty soft right
yeah
um i i would call it because they
started that def leppard started that
pop metal thing really and so it's
really hard for me to say yeah
well like what um
did they do an actual power but they
must have def leppard has got to be well
bringing on the heartbreak they're
considered a classic power ballad but
that's an interesting one
because arguably you know there's a
shift in sound with def leppard so
arguably they are
within the mainstream of you know
regular heavy metal and then they become
they then they shift towards being more
uh pop or light or they actually they
would get criticized as being too
american by a lot of a lot of people
that's true and what's the one they had
um well the 90s they started their
powerballs with uh have you ever watched
someone so bad
i would consider that a power ballad
well and and i think there's some off of
hysteria as well um
yeah they had definitely tapped in by
that time to like well what what are
people looking for i i i for me i
remember being very disappointed with
the hysteria album even though it was
one of their best sellers
you know
and i always have this
gripe with them i don't pay to see them
for like the last 15 years because every
time i buy a ticket it is hysteria in
its entirety and then a couple like
obligatory and i'm i remember one time i
think um on the slang tour was at 95 or
something i really liked that album and
they maybe played one song from that
album and i said if we're gonna do in
the round every year count me out you
know their live dvd in the round yeah
and i'm a big def leopard fan but um
you know uh well that's a that's a whole
other episode right you know
uh
setless
yeah and whether there's any sort of
ethical obligations involved in that so
we'll put that to the side we should
start talking about like we promised to
talk a little bit about how do we define
power ballads and ballads so before we
actually get into
more geeking out about specific songs
let's let's talk about um some some key
things so what you know we can start
with like thinking about species and
genera in a very uh philosophical sense
what is a ballad as such and that's a
tough one to define because
it already has multiple definitions
ballads go all the way back into the
middle ages and then they kind of get
redefined
it was interesting because i found that
power ballads and rock ballads in
general get classified as being part of
a special kind of ballot sentimental
ballot and i think that makes sense so
that's an emotional style of music that
often deals with romantic
intimate relationships to a lesser
extent loneliness death war drug abuse
politics and religion
usually in a poignant but solemn manner
this is coming from curtis's rock eras
interpretations of music and society and
and we can say okay
ballads in general and and you know are
going to be slower in tempo they tend to
be more lush in their arrangement
they're trying to you know appeal to our
our emotions
what about power ballads as such so i
i've got a bunch of different takes on
this and i think we can kick these
around before we we get to heavy metal
power balance so
simon firth says a power ballad is a
slow tempo song often often building to
a loud and emotive chorus backed by
drums electric guitars and sometimes
choirs and i think that's that's that's
true
charles aaron says and he's talking less
about the definition and more about the
origin they came into an existence in
the early 70s when rock stars attempted
to convey profound messages to audiences
while retaining their macho rocker
mystique and then david metzner who's
written several articles on power
ballads
says the crux of the musical formulation
is escalation
power ballads climb up from relatively
quiet introspective openings through a
series of expressive plateaus each more
intense than the last the ascent is made
through a gradual increase in dynamics
and the size and density of the ensemble
i really like that i think that's that's
dead on
and then he also says something else
really quite interesting ballads court
intimacy
a singer imparts what comes across as
deeply felt emotions and draws in
listeners through delicate candor so we
got like two different sets of things
going on here we've got
attention to dynamics and
we could call it orchestration right the
musical elements as such and then we
have attention to
the lyrical
content you know what what what are
power ballads about and
and i think it's important that you know
there's this idea that conveying
conveying profound messages to audiences
while retaining the macho rocker
mystique
that is going to be a tough tension
within heavy metal not so much in other
genres i mean if you're barry manilow
who does actually have some arguably
some power balance hey you can sing
whatever you want and nobody's going to
be like um
you know you're not you're not very
metal man because he's not metal
[Laughter]
oh mandy right mandy's a classic power
ballad i would think yeah because
there's no orchestration and
it's it's got all those other elements
um
so
what do you make of these definitions
i don't agree power ballot
yeah i don't agree with the escalation i
mean look i think the greatest power
ballad is reason to live by kiss starts
off with a drum thing
so it's um but it's got the synth thing
going on which is kind of like
mostly a pad
um the tempo is slower but the power
ballads
usually have a straight four on the
floor rock beat that's repetitive in
this case it is
um and the crescendo is only in the
choruses you know where it's like
layered harmonies where he sings
everybody's got a reason to live and
then it comes back down for the second
part of the story and then it goes back
up so i think i don't think that that
formula is quite i mean like stairway to
heaven is not a power ballad but it has
all those things in there
well a lot of people consider that one
of the early power ballads but you know
the end is definitely rock and roll it's
not something slow about the whole
guitar solo and as we played
that's so that's just an up rock tune
right there
does does reason to live have i i forget
does it have a uh
a bridge in it with like a solo or
anything yep it's got a good parcel and
then it then it moves keys it moves
you know i kind of think that that's
also a distinctive i guess i i think the
escalation thing it doesn't have to be
quite so formulaic as well you start out
a
plateau one then two then three
but i kind of think that
unless it's a different kind of song
having a key change is kind of a
giveaway
oh yeah it does escalate but the thing
about reason to live that's the big
money part is where everything drops out
but that impressionist keyboard kind of
okay you know everything drops out and
then the drums come back in and then
it's just paul stanley like reflecting
on what happened so and then it kind of
fades out yeah yeah so um well i think
that could be part of a traditional
power ballad it doesn't necessarily have
to end on like the high note with right
all horns blazing or something like that
maybe i could end with the
you know the little outro you know on
the piano or something well they do the
same thing with uh forever right so it's
kind of like they end
forever with that reflective kind of you
know we've said all this and you know
here's this kind of outro thing yeah a
little bit unique and i always found it
the reflective part of the song where i
kind of like wow and i really enjoy
songs that have that kind of opportunity
i mean desmond child wrote the first one
with paul stanley but i think it was
just paul that wrote forever which was
a fantastic powerpoint you know i think
yeah
you know he
paul's a great songwriter you know he he
wrote
you know we were saying there's shandy a
powerball no i just think that's just a
pop tune
yeah yeah yeah
and and um well we're going to come into
the things that are that are not power
ballads in a bit but let's talk about
the heavy metal parts so
i think one way that people might try to
define it which doesn't really work is
well power ballads are just you know or
heavy metal power ballads are just
power ballads that are recorded by a
heavy metal band or that have a typical
heavy metal sound there's got to be a
little bit more to that in part because
the power ballad is in some respects um
it's genre defying it crosses over from
from one to the next
and you know back in the time that scott
and i were growing up and i think this
may even carry through uh in some some
areas of heavy metal today there's a
perception that the power ballad is kind
of a sellout it's not really metal it's
so you can become you know as we're
talking about def leppard you know you
can get a bigger airplay metallica i got
got dinged for this with the black album
which has a power ballad on it
yeah now they actually have some other
power balances we're going to talk about
before that but nothing else matters is
much more power bality than ever
that's the one yeah now mark says asking
for clarification the power part of the
definition is what is characterized by
this escalation
as opposed to other types of ballads
that lack such escalation yeah so if
we're thinking in terms of like dynamics
right
soft versus
and we could use a couple different
terms
loud heavy hard but not not too loud not
too heavy right if you go from
you know it's kind of a nice acoustic
intro
to
um
something that's you know
uh very fast with you know say like
death metal grawling okay you don't have
a power ballot there
so so
but there is going to be some dynamic
stuff and we'll talk a bit more about
that
so i i think that in order to think
about the heavy metal part it's useful
to bring in as we've done so often dina
weinstein and her
sociology of heavy metal
you know in the 1970s heavy metal is
kind of an ill-defined developing and
expanding musical genre it's got roots
and blues and psychedelic rock and other
heavy rock um the music critics hated it
and you know would use heavy metal as a
term of a program it got viewed as a
dying genre you know disco's killing it
punk is killing it and at the same time
that people were saying this it was
going through this massive underground
vitalization that that led to you know
the la scene
and
bands like twisted sister in the new
york scene like finally recording and
the massive massive stuff that was
happening with the new wave of british
heavy metal and also you know german
metal and japanese metal at the time
as well so
by the time that we get to the 80s it
starts to become a more coherent
super genre you could say and dina
weinstein
identifies three main early sub genres
now this doesn't work for like the 1990s
onward when the genres go in a whole
bunch of different directions
but she says there's there's traditional
heavy metal in the middle
this would be represented by bands like
judas priest or iron maiden ozzy
osbourne
um you know
rainbow in the 70s uh d.o in in the 80s
in his solo career um
other other smaller bands like syrah
ungol or
um
uh armored saint you know would be
fitting in there as well and then
there's um on the further side you've
got speed or thrash metal now speed has
always been kind of an ill-defined thing
as well
but you do see thrash metal as one of
the early extreme metals developing and
it's not just a matter of like musical
stuff it's also like how you dress and
what sort of things you'll do so there's
less you know
speed is speed and thrash are kind of at
the other end of glam
and you even see them you know making
fun of of that sort of thing and then
you have
whatever we want to call it she calls it
metal light
lit right yeah but it's glam it's pop
it's it's whatever is kind of you know
it's still metal e
but it's not it doesn't have the
credibility that iron maiden has right
or that metallica has or that
um
you know if we want to pick another
uh um
thrash band metal church later on in the
in the evening oh right yeah yeah right
uh and then some bands kind of straddle
this so like rat rat is hard to pin down
they look very glammy their music is
very polished um and yet they kind of
fit into that traditional thing quite
well there
as opposed to say
um slaughter which is definitely much
more towards the the glam side right
than than rat would be or motley crue
starts out very you know very much on
the one side and then they kind of
meander
but but every once in a while they'll
have like a really heavy song you know
so i think this is useful um and
weinstein says this light metal is
sweetened heavy metal the sub-genre is
especially known for its power balance
which are songs with just enough metal
sound which she says is base
to be heard as metal but not so much
metal sound that they will be detested
by those who are turned off by
traditional heavy metal power ballads
have been played on radio stations that
typically exclude heavy metal right
so i think she's she's she's dead on
with this and you know the experience of
your mom
uh you know liking uh which which song
was it was uh anyway yeah
um
i think i think she's she's right about
this so it's interesting because if
they're so if we've got this three-part
division right
white traditional um thrash
speed the power bailouts are more going
to be on this side and a band that does
too many of them could be viewed as like
sliding itself
into the light side right right
now
oh sorry go ahead well i was gonna i'm
gonna throw this question out for you um
back in the day a lot of people would
say well that's not really heavy metal
you know of bands that that did a lot of
um
power balance what do you think about
that
i mean i'm trying to go back to the time
right so
um that's where you walked around the
mall and then you had a green jacket and
it was kind of um
you know i i had you know when metallica
in the 80s when they were coming out
like we're talking master of puppets
here and stuff well that became the real
tough guy stuff you know yeah yeah all
of a sudden it's it's really heavy and
then it it's kind of like well i like
metal i like white snake and you get the
white sticks not metal you know or um
and for some reason we all knew back
then right we we just knew it was just
the x factor it's just kind of like but
you and i always say it's like if it
made to the back of the tough guy jacket
there's ac dc well they're not a metal
band they're a rock and roll band but
they make it on with iron maiden yeah
get on with
um
but i think a big thing here is what you
said earlier is the lyric content so in
other words
um iron maiden doesn't sing about love
really you know um until later there's
they have a power ballad on on one of
their later albums and it and it's
terrible
which one am i what am i uh was it in
the 80s
no it's it's later on let me scroll down
in the show notes wasting love
which
interestingly enough
um
it's by dickinson and yannick gares
oh
interesting i i you know what album is
that on one of their albums or is it it
is on an album and i actually watched
the video for it and i was like well you
know i like iron maiden
and then i was like wow this is this is
pretty schmaltzy you know
because if we if we jump ahead um just a
little bit and then we'll come back to
talking about the definition stuff right
so with iron maiden with early early
iron maiden they arguably have some some
things that can be classified as power
ballads
but they're not the typical lyrical
content of oh i love you so much girl i
wish you hadn't gone away you know
um remember tomorrow right yeah that's a
power ballad right it has the elements
it starts out very
you know uh pensive
um soft and by the time that you get to
the middle of it it's it's rocking right
um but then it has a slowdown
back to the same thing
um and that's paul deano you know so i
want to so you you must have seen live
at the rainbow mark maybe you've seen
that uh maiden with paul diana live at
the rainbow and
something that that that you
had said earlier um
i forget who's who you quoted saying it
but you have to re retain the macho
image so i'll never forget him
announcing it going you know really
tough with his with the spikes and
everything number 12
you know and
you know he still made it a total tough
guy macho thing and um his stance and
everything was still pretty metal it
wasn't like they sat down with acoustic
guitars and yeah um
i mean it's a beautiful song you know i
mean
literally beautiful you know um i don't
know that you could say that about like
running free running free is an awesome
song but it's not a beautiful song you
know
there's another maiden song so let me
see what you think and what what any you
know mark thanks and anybody else would
think about this one um
i didn't originally think of this
somebody proposed this when we were
doing sort of the polling about you know
favorite power ballots
children of the damned off of uh number
of the beast is that a
power ballot it it certainly has some of
the elements of it
um lyrically it's about it you know uh
children who are like burning like
candles in the night so
not your usual affair but
i don't know is is it
ah you know i guess if it's powerball or
is it just a
slower dismal tune or something i always
i never i never called it a well did i
ever call it a ballad i remember
yeah i guess i guess it would because
it's got the straight back beat
um it's
it does have a point where like things
speed up
right right
yeah right exactly
but it's finishing out
going back to the slower
uh that's right it goes back to the
intro part
yeah
so what do you think is it a power
ballad
or or do we have to talk about things
that are power ballad
esque but maybe missing
some of the
most central elements oh it is a power
ballot i'm i'm singing it in my head
okay um and uh
you know it's so funny because it's like
i always remember that part where you
know the band's quiet bruce dickinson's
like crescendoing he goes yeah you know
it would have crucified them all and the
response was just these like harmonics
on the guitar
yeah so the band you know kind of stays
low it's muted you could say the band is
is
yeah the band is down and dickinson kind
of floats all around yeah but then it
gets but even the tempo doesn't change
when it goes it's the same progression
but then the distorted guitars come and
follow the baseline in between the the
verses so yeah
it is a power ballad okay
mark says that he says he doesn't feel
like one to him but thinking now he
can't justify why and this is this is
the very interesting thing right with a
lot of these things
until we actually have to think about it
sort of like saint augustine and
confessions he says somebody asked me
what time is if you don't ask me i know
what it is as soon as somebody puts me
on the spot i don't have i don't have a
clue right
it's this
activity of articulating ourselves
so mark says i guess it's the lyrical
element it's really grim yeah so maybe
we should talk about grim power ballads
as being a subclass of them
it doesn't build to a hopeful climax it
builds to despair
and i mean they're right i mean that
makes me think of like
you know early black sabbath songs
um
[Music]
they there there really isn't a power
ballad in there but that is something
that's characteristic of them
and i would say of a lot of traditional
heavy metal that
um it's it's not just about romance or
stuff like that it's about it's about
bigger themes of of negative affects
right
so let's talk about things that are not
power balanced and then then we'll talk
we'll get a little bit deeper especially
with scott here into the
musical
um
aspect of it so
we want to say power ballads are
different from a different kind of song
that also has
oftentimes crescendos or stuff like that
anthems right so
anthems usually have like you know
themes of like
um
worrying it together or you know um
fighting or stuff like that so triumphs
fight the good fight when we were
talking about
that me and scott before that we were
like is that a power ballad and we're
like no it's definitely not a power
ballad even though it has you know leads
in
with um
uh you know kind of a heavy thing and
then it gets soft and then it gets hard
again
um
what else uh
skid rows youth gone wild not really a
power ballad no but that's an anthem
yeah yeah or kisses rock and roll all
although right
and another one actually two other ones
that we talked about i thought really
interesting because my wife proposed
dio's rainbow in the dark
and i thought yeah okay i guess that
it's heavy but it could be a power
ballad but then when we talked about it
no it's not really a power ballad right
the tempo is too fast i think so that's
a key aspect yeah
yeah i mean yeah if it was if you slowed
it down it would qualify for it if you
played it
a little slower i wonder you know what
that would sound like wouldn't you need
to like
take the verses maybe and soften them
too
yeah because the the guitar riff is is
pretty heavy
i mean it's consistent yeah
um
no i i just think that's a
cool rock metal tune yeah i think that
dio has tons of anthems mark brings up
the last in line um well i think all the
full sail away was the only do power
ballad i could think of and that's
that's a later one yeah that's that's on
um
the first uh that album with craig
goldie the 1991 what's it called um
dream evil that's right yeah yeah which
i like that but you know another one
that we talked about and i was pushing
for this originally as being a power
ballad and scott talked me out of it
into being an anthem
is judas priests um the rage
i mean it starts out with this
bass solo
and it's not you know um
anastasia pulling teeth kind of bass so
it's a nice measured thing
it's got this uh kind of off beat guitar
intro thing playing on you know just
just uh white chords
um and then you know there's this the
singing slow about you know uh
this rage that we're feeling and then it
builds to a huge crescendo you know
um
but it's not really a power ballot it is
more of an anthem you know
yeah i mean um
well you know it's so funny because
anthems and power balance are so
different when we hear them if you're
gonna sit someone down and say this is a
power ballad this is an anthem they'd be
like well there's no comparison however
the more you and i talk about it there's
some of that venn diagram overlap okay
yeah i mean um
d schneider
recently
did a um
a softer version of we're not going to
take it a slowed down version if we're
not going to take it
oh really
and i i don't remember it that well but
i wonder if that couldn't be considered
power ballady oh so so mark has a great
question here what about deep purple's
child in time definitely has like that
building going on it's a long song you
know
i mean some people have proposed that as
a power ballad
yeah deep purple you know i didn't
that's really interesting because i
for some reason greg i didn't start
scouring deep purple at all like i
i found a song off of an album
um that that doesn't get much play from
the 90s
where joel and turner replaced um
ian gillen
called king of dreams and it's a
powerful yeah yeah oh god and look you
know when joel and turner left and did
his first solo album um
uh endlessly is an amazing power ballad
that was his big hit yeah that's a that
is a power ballad i mean maybe that's
what it took for deep purple to have
like a power ballad power ball it was to
bring
turner in
well that's you know that was a very
different yeah ironically though i mean
you think about it uh david coverdale
that's where he got his start right
white snake is a power ballad heavy
uh band right one really one of the most
prolific power ballad bands in the 1980s
and
is there a power ballad dating from deep
purple's uh uh with 1973 or 1975 got a
burn arrow tenure with him i i don't i
don't think so
um
no he was no because
that yeah the whole burn era was just
pedal to the metal yeah and even come
taste the band with um uh the oh god um
tommy ball tommy bohlen yeah that's such
a great record but they got kind of
funky like it was metal groove stuff
which i like
i was just listening to that album the
other day i really like it a lot but
there's no there's nothing like that
that's like a power ball down there it's
all
mark actually asked about uriah heap and
we we kicked around some of those you
know like maybe gypsy but gypsy starts
out too heavy you know
heavy guitar and organ riff at the same
time
um bird of prey same sort of deal
you know um
so i you know they have ballads
so and this is this is a distinction we
want to make right so there are metal
bands and i think that uriah heap is a
metal band i think they're they're part
of early 70s metal um
where they have a ballad but it's not a
power ballad black sabbath had some of
those right uh solitude um changes those
are those are ballots um even uh goodbye
to romance right that's a ballad
that's interesting because uh
i don't know if that's it's so much a
power ballad it's just a ballad it gets
into the lists of things that are that
that people are calling power balance
but maybe maybe yeah it's not um
does it have uh does it have like a big
or you know crescendo
no i mean it's
it it is maybe rhodes in him like randy
wrote the leo brower thing at the time
with uh with diary of a madman and yeah
i mean a lot of people want to say
silent lucidity by queens reich as a
power ballad but no it doesn't it
doesn't have the power you know right
and like more than words by extreme it's
just a ballad
yeah
that's another one that that a lot of
people want to put in there as well
um also i would say uh rainbows catch
the rainbow is about to talk about that
right talked about that yeah
that's right you brought that one up
yeah it lacks the heaviness that we need
yeah
yeah so you know the power has to have
the distorted guitars coming in
at the right time um yeah there were
bands out of la that followed this that
were like um
icon if if you guys remember icon they
didn't really make it huge but like
their album was
power balance and then you have vinnie
vincent invasion it's all the only tunes
that made the radio were um love kills
right
kind of a power and then that time of
year i don't know if that time of year
is a power ballad though
no because it
they're they're just mid-tempo rock
tunes i think mark says you need those
distorted guitars coming in the last
third yeah or they could it could come
in earlier for the chorus if they
haven't
you got to have like shifting dynamics
and we'll just mention one other song
that's that's not a power ballad but
sometimes gets put in the lists
which does have shifting hard soft
dynamics but it's it's probably more if
we want to say it's a ballad at all it's
just a ballad and that's bluisters call
blue oyster cults don't fear the reaper
yeah it's not it's not a power ballad
yeah
especially having that you know i know
they joke about the cowbell but the
cowbell doing this
there's no there's no ballad there you
know
um i mean you in the 80s you you could
have some uh
uh power balance that might have a
cowbell
from time to time
[Music]
mark asks what you think about astronomy
so this is a good question oh
no i just think that's uh
that's boc that's them doing um
they were reading a lot of science
fiction they were really into actually
that the lyrics of that song don't make
a lot of sense to me um
i i don't think it's i think it's a
no i don't think it's a power ballad
okay
the only power ballad that they had was
on revolution by night um it's called
eyes on fire
that's like that's blue oyster cults
power balance
and it's funny um buck said they they
played it a few times the year the album
came out i would love to hear it live
but it's very not like them you know
yeah it's kind of like well we tried
this power ballad thing or or he didn't
say powerball but he said you know
you know we we wrote a song not about
like you know
um like agents of fortune or anything we
wrote a love song you know yeah and
that's not our in our wheelhouse but it
made the album
well let's let's switch gears a little
bit and talk about um musical
elements we've already referenced some
of these so there's this contrast right
there has to be
a contrast in it or it's not really a
power ballad it can't start out super
hot and heavy or fast
um there can be a faster part of the
song
but but a lot of power ballads
right scott just retained the same
temple throughout the entire thing yeah
i mean once you get into like you i'll
just use the stairway to heaven thing
that that's not a power ballad because
there's nothing powerful about
any part of the song and then the end of
the song is
kind of a hard rock thing yeah right so
there's no there's ballot into hard rock
but there's no power bound to me so
is it that there's not a significant
transition like a building is that part
of it
no i think you know it's just acoustic
guitar um some flute sounds from the
keyboard and uh
and a singing so it's almost like a like
a minor sounding folk tune
right
and then at the end they have the
traffic
but it's not um
no there's nothing
uh
there's nothing power valid about it to
me and that's interesting like even on
in through the outdoor did zeppelin have
anything that
required i don't think zeppelin touched
power ballad right even zeppelin 3 was
mostly folky
and then you know like acoustic folky
like friends and all that stuff and yeah
um yeah i mean i i kind of think that
quite a few of the 70s bands
in in the let's call it the metal
spectrum right there's debates is led
zeppelin heavy metal or not well
certainly some of their songs are right
um but maybe in so far as they are doing
things that can be considered metal it's
not even like close to a power ballad
you know
i mean no quarter
uh i don't know if we could call that a
power ballad
that's something else it's just a kind
of a slower very dark song this is a
really interesting observation
led zeppelin feel like they should have
been the band to create power ballads
but i don't think any of their songs
count i mean i think that's also
something we can say about uriah heap
too if any band should have created
given the lyrical content they have like
sunrise you know
you know and that that's one that that
if if any of them were going to be a
power ballad i think sunrise would have
been the one to to make into it um but i
i don't think that they really did
generate what we what we identify as
power ballots
you know
so let's talk about some of the other
musical aspects um vocals right
you see this reference to operatic
singing the high-end anthemic choruses
um i mean you're a musician
albeit not a singer but you've worked
with many many many singers
what goes into singing a power ballad is
it is there something distinctive about
the way you sing that that
makes it power bality
um
well i you know like i've said
well like i've observed with a lot of
them you know thinking about this one of
the things that the power ballads do
have in common
is
uh
the band
is is is you know uh the tempo is a
little slower the band is the guitarist
are picking and choosing where they're
gonna play
you know but the singer can can
belt out the singer has the freedom i
mean
um even if you think of still loving you
klaus starts off kind of whatever but
the second you hit the pre-chorus he's
already up there yeah and he's screaming
by the chorus and then he comes back
down
um
so
uh well you know
i know this is not very technical
sounding but uh as far as
you know maybe a lot of it is like a
voice is a power ballot because think
think of like
mark knopfler from dire straits there's
no way he could sing a power ballad
because he doesn't you know what i mean
he doesn't yeah
he doesn't have the voice for it right
so
um
you know he has he has a voice for a
ballad
but um so you know i guess if you're
you're saying like you know uh a game
you could play with it is okay take
still loving you and mark knopfler
singing it is it still a power ballad
and so that's one of the elements i
think it's it's key that you're saying
well
singer play into this um
uh i think there's you know there might
be less rules for the singer than the
band and the tempo
i was struck by you talking about the
guitar player and i do want to talk
about guitars in just a minute but i was
thinking um
it's almost as if in the softer parts
you have to think in terms of negative
space what's not happening there right
sort of like a painting where you've got
blank spots and the blank spots are
significative um you're playing slow if
there's like an arpeggio you're actually
letting there be space between the notes
whereas like when we get to the harder
heavier more energetic part it's like a
wall of sound right
you know this is i just thought of this
now um i was on an album in 2001 as a
singer lois greco
um and i worked with her a lot in the
90s and there's a power ballad on that
album okay
you know um
so she she wrote the the the chords and
everything and me and her brother who
was a bass player we said okay
how are we going to lay this out
right
so i'm trying to think uh and she's like
a very powerful singer right you know i
wouldn't say operatic but you know kind
of operatic like the
high notes
um and we actually shaped the tune out
we didn't use the word power ballad but
we knew that's what we were doing
right and then we she had another song
called you are that was just really a
ballad and we treated that one very
differently i'm sorry
i totally oh no i'd love to hear about
this yeah and um so uh not to jump ahead
to the guitar but
um
the verses
i would like you know have a distorted
sound and kind of like follow the bass
line a little or
like you said the negative space
and i would stop when she had a phrase
that was particularly powerful
but all bets off with the court
you know
it's just you know the marshall cranked
and oh yeah of course she was like
belting it out and then she would stack
all these harmonies and then we come
back down until we hit this big bridge
key change to the
key change to the guitar solo um
so i forgot that i've been you know i've
been on
i've recorded power balance and not till
you just said that and mentioned the
stuff that that level find away was the
name of the song
and um
it was i would say
the power ballad
um in this case is very triumphant you
know but it's okay yeah you know like
yeah
um
i mean it seems so like mark is saying
the vocals are front and center from the
earlier parts of the song the singer has
to have the chops to carry and i think
that the chops so there's two kinds of
chops being demanded right the being
able to like sing on your own and have
um you know a voice that's that's
attractive that that promotes like uh
reflection was a word scott used earlier
on
and then you know once you get to the
large
energetic part of the song where the
guitarist the bass the drummer they're
all playing full out maybe there's even
a keyboard in there something like that
well yeah of course the singer has to be
able to float on top of that and just
punch it out so they can have a powerful
voice
to be able to do a power ballot
yeah and you know um you said it
perfectly with the negative space the
verses have to like bring back
to to bring you up so to speak the
roller coaster effect or you're kind of
going up right over the edge you know um
i really think it is in the you know you
have to map it out and you know it's why
people like desmond child were producing
everybody and producing some of the best
power ballads even you know um when cher
did that album in 87 there were songs
written by michael bolton but heavier
songs okay um
so but you have to bring desmond child
in desmond child has to get the
musicians have the whole thing so that
cher could just come and do what he says
you know but yeah
but that she's not a heavy metal singer
but uh of course but um yeah mal was
kind of that crossover person about
he would have been amazing to have on
here because he might even have a
specific formula um
because i kind of i kind of suspect that
there is not all power ballads fit a
formula but i suspect that there are
like formulas that somebody could say
all right now we're going to do this now
we're going to do this now we're going
to do this
so before we talk more about guitar
though um so the rhythm section the the
drum you know there is like a
distinctive
kind of drumming you could say to doing
power ballads and it's it's not you know
super virtuosic it's you know but what
about the base is there is there
anything distinctive when you think
about
power ballads that the bassist is
contributing or is it just kind of like
well the bass just happens to be there
uh no the big we'll see here's the
opportunity for a good bass player okay
to um because there is a lot more space
because the tempo has to be slower i
mean there's right right like we said
some of them
you know
um
are a little faster it's like okay
you're out of you're out of balance all
together but
the the bass and a lot of them you hear
them play whole notes right or follow
the kick drum boom
boom
but
a really good bass player and i wish i
could think of an example right now i
probably will but
um is to play the note and then when
there's space after the singer do a
slight melodic
um because the bass doing a melodic
response to the singer is very different
from a guitarist doing it the bass kind
of sneaks by people but they they do
hear it like yeah if you were to take
that out everybody would be like hey
what happened to the song you know
um but you know
and then just the subtle things like a
bass player sliding into the note these
very subtle things that
that everybody notices but maybe they
can't
um
[Music]
justify but the bass player could be
more lyrical
a guitar player doing that kind of stuff
like fills might be a little too much
for it but the bass can
really um
yeah i mean uh if you listen to them
just there's always little subtleties
usually if there's a good producer
they'll get the bass player to play
these little subtleties where it's a
slide or you sustain
this one or you just answer it with
you know like a little pentatonic thing
back to the next chord so the b
and the drums have to be straight
uh i'm trying i can't think of a power
valve where it's not four on the floor
but a slow four on the floor yeah you
know um
yeah even like still loving you and
reason to live and all that they're very
steady even even in like the the heavy
part right it doesn't transform into
that like precision
kind of drumming right
exactly yeah
yeah so um yeah if you think of the the
course of still avenue is basically the
same a little hitting a little harder
but it's not easier okay
um
and i think you depending on what it is
you have to really watch your
syncopations although any good rock
drummer won't you know if you get like a
gospel kind of drummer trying to do
those they
and i've played in situations rock bands
with
more r b type or soul players and
they hear the eighth notes very
differently so
particularly on these tunes more
straight
okay so it's like yeah like the fill you
were talking about it's like that would
be completely inappropriate um
yeah
um even the reason to live uh one is
that's it
right so it's not syncopated it's very
straight it's very yeah yeah um
so the rhythm section i mean it's uh
playing the power ballad correctly is an
art you don't just take people and say
here's some charts and i'll make it
sound good you know half the time we
won't get it that's an interesting thing
to say because that comes back to this
like perception uh
in the let's call it the metal sphere
that well you know power ballads i mean
that's more for like the light metal
bands that aren't quite as good as the
real metal bands and what you're saying
is no actually it requires
uh a lot of talent to do it well you
know
well it doesn't you know um
bands like alias i don't know if you
ever remember them
um
they were doing a lot of power but like
the power ballad there were certain
bands that were like b bands like they
sold records but they didn't do really
good
um
but you i mean it's like any other style
of music you um
you have to
you i mean it's got it's got its swing
every music happens so
i i guess people are when they criticize
it for not being metal they're not
saying it's not technically as
professional yeah mark says power
ballads have their tech name they have
their own particular skill involved in
it yeah well yeah it's you know and i
see people take that for granted in all
genres where like i said i've done rock
gigs
where an r b drummer will show up and
they've listened to the music on the way
up and they don't understand how the
eighth note is supposed to go and they
think that they're you know they're the
big guy on the street so to speak like
you know i'm the king of this club i'm
the best drummer i've got the most chops
and my favorite was one guy came in and
did a gig which was a very four on the
floor eighth note power pop gig
and the drummer got fired in the second
tune told the pack of his drums and
leave
and um and the look on his face was like
well but i'm amazing you know yeah
going to what mark says um well you're
not you're amazing at maybe what you do
but you're not being musical right now
and you don't understand where the
eighth note belongs you know it's very
remedial stuff yeah you know you could
say that a lot of people think that
amazing or talented or things like that
are terms that refer to
like across the board they're
they're scalar terms and you've got like
you know a continuum of you know the
sucky all the way to the awesome
but it's it's not quite like that
instead it's more like it's always
qualified you're great with respect to
this right a lot of times the really
great musicians are the ones who can
span multiple
um genres or styles or or things like
that and and have equal proficiency
in them you know um rather than the
virtuosos who are really really good at
this this specialized niche over here
you know there is one other thing i
wanted to bring up before mark has a
great um
uh comment here that i want to get back
to but
the guitars right so we talked about the
singer we talked about the rhythm
section
you're a guitarist
i'm sure you've given a lot of thought
to what's going on in power ballads in
terms of guitar i mean what i can say
the only thing that i really have to
contribute is you know in a power ballad
the guitar when it's soloing it's
lyrical it's not nobody's shredding
power balance right i agree
um
i would say just i agree with that um
but there's some people in times that
would break the rule and kind of ruin
the song because somebody says
well you know like a guitar yeah a cool
tap thing at the end like a very fast
thing and it's like
that didn't belong yeah you know
you can tell it's the insecurity of the
guitarist going i don't want people
think i suck so you're
a very kind of uh
melodic singable kind of phrase even if
it's just the part you come up with
well i mean still loving you is like
the archetype of that right you you
think about the soloing in that and you
know so was that uh
that's mattias jobs right because yeah
it's after the leave on roth yeah oh
yeah no it is yeah
and you know uh jobs can certainly solo
faster or
you know more intricately than that but
every every note like
it it fits
it's so good yeah that's solo at the end
and you know what's funny is
being younger
we always wanted to be so fast but we
all wanted to learn that solo because it
i think it touched us all it was just
yeah yeah really like you know
it was awesome what do you think what's
this remark uh from mark i always viewed
the guitar solo in power ballads is the
musical metaphor for a weeping heart
and this isn't a power ballad but like
toto's um
[Music]
oh god what's that song but uh
it's off of toto for it's uh
but anyway steve luca there just has a
solo that literally just goes uh
[Music]
right
and it's like crying
whatever so like you know but it's just
and it's one of my favorite solos and
everybody's everybody says like you know
he's a shred lord but on these ballas he
comes up with this and i agree
the whaling the you know the the um the
crying
and that's really you know
that's gonna
have people respond to things more and
that's not the time to show off your
chops or not the time
yeah yeah
that's interesting so in some ways a
power ballad demands restraint right
even on the powerful parts
i think i wouldn't use the word
restraint i'd use the word right frame
of mind like um huh okay i have this
it doesn't really fit but i say to my
students i have an acronym called wait
why am i talking
[Laughter]
so
um so then if if i'm playing something
and a student's playing and improvising
with no breath in in the plane i i use
that and i said or in this case why am i
playing yeah yeah
um
not shredded cheese but cream cheese
um but it's yeah well you know also uh a
protein flavorful
yes it's true
um
but i i really think um
you have to have the right frame of mind
like how am i serving the music or am i
serving myself i mean we get pretty
philosophical and i give my students
these tools yeah i'll come up with these
demos and i'm like look you sound great
but that's completely inappropriate like
you know you're that's a session for
somebody else if you want to do that on
your own album that's okay
but you know when somebody's hiring you
for a session you
you know you have their best interests
and you know if there's a producer you
want to listen to the producer and try
i always say you know you might get mad
at producers because they might not like
anything you do however
think of it as they're challenging
your um
the integrity of your musicianship take
it as what do i need to work on and can
you deliver maybe not today but maybe
tomorrow and i think that's
if somebody's doing um
uh
kind of serving the music
uh it's gonna it's gonna come out okay
although a lot of people that play uh
well i shouldn't say a lot of people
some people that play really fast don't
have
the timing to play slower they haven't
developed it because they went right
onto you know the speed
or they can't like lay back a little bit
and get that whaling effect or that
that emotional thing and that's a that's
really difficult to do to play a really
touching
melodic statement on a on a power ballot
in this sense
yeah yeah
but yeah that would still even use a
great one it was just you know we all
wanted to learn it because it was
it just sounded great right and it was
cool that we could play it because we
couldn't play his other stuff
he was too good
well what else what else about the
guitar i mean
there's the early stuff where maybe it
might be acoustic or you're playing like
you know soft arpeggios or something
like that right yeah
or even just a melodic line you know um
and then
what's what's happening with the guitar
once you hit the
the
i don't know whatever you want to call
it the tipping point of the power ballad
well um
i always you know so the verses there's
a lot of approaches
uh you could take you know kind of like
the um you want to be
the way i look at it anyways is
i'm here to serve texture because this
is the the drum beats
solid the bass is solid yeah that's
holding down like the you know like you
said the kind of the macho thing where
it's still kind of a backbeat you know
and it's still but so whether it's um
some clean sounds with a little delay
with a volume pedal like sneaking in
little responses
or
non-consistent things however when we
get to the pre-chorus
i want to start being a little more
consistent
and then the the chorus
um
longer chords but heavier more power
chords like you know like i'm really
kind of filling in the low end with you
know kind of the sonic thing yeah
but also
not
i have to be careful not to like strum
too much um because you have to
completely stay out of the way of the
vocalists rhythms whatever so so
strumming would call too much attention
to the guitar
no it would just not be appropriate like
you know it's still loving you it's
something like yeah
[Music]
yeah
right so they're just
and so the bass is probably coming along
for the ride on that too just playing
long
as you're saying whole notes but
sustaining them right maybe maybe longer
than whole notes like across a couple
measures
well maybe but
that's an opportunity for the bass
player to respond a little bit because
they're in the lower range they're
completely out of the vocal range
and that's where they can do i mean
but like you know if you have like uh
instead of me going
the drummer might have like uh
[Music]
yeah yeah
right so like it could be like a little
bit where i would be intrusive if i did
it okay um but the bass player like has
can have those sensitive moments where
they're kind of sliding and i think that
adds a lot um
but yeah i mean if we're talking power
balance it's a very straight eighth note
thing
right i can't think of one that's not
yeah
yeah i mean that we that we've said that
we've agreed upon well let's let's look
at some of the examples then maybe we'll
get some weird stuff coming out of that
so you know in 1970s we've talked about
this a lot of people have brought up
nazareth's lovehurts as a good example i
i think that actually is a good idea you
know actually you know what yeah
um kisses i want you
yes i think that's a power ballad um
aerosmith's dream dream on
arguably you know 1971 yeah yeah um ufos
love to love i of i'm not sure i'm sold
on that does that have enough of the
like big
you know
or is this is it more bality but not
metal power bality
um
but
yeah it's not as straight it doesn't
later on in the song it's not as
straight as is yeah
that might disqualify it as far as the
rhythm
yeah one of the other ones that is
definitely
not a love song but i i think is like a
great 70s power ballad the scorpion's
riot of your time
you know it's got it starts out with the
guitar
you know it's it's pretty soft
it's it is a little fast i suppose
um
but
i kind of think that that qualifies but
then you know two other ones that get
brought up a lot that i'd be interested
to hear your views on this so judas
priest here come the tears is that a
power ballad
i mean it starts out you know
with this very like crewnery
right
thing and you know it's slow the guitars
are
pretty muted
and what a great title for it yeah by
the time that he's done though or the
time that they're done um
you know
rob halford is way way the hell up here
the guitars are you know moving ahead
but it's still a slow
beat right
i mean yeah uh
god you know i didn't even think of that
one
it's romantic and sappy as hell well i
was just saying like you know here come
to tears what did that title alone says
power balance once i dreamed love would
come in sweep me up away
but now i see that life's passed me by
oh yeah i mean
oh yeah i mean
they'll be interesting to like do a test
where you just put lyrics in front of
somebody power balance without hearing
it yeah potentially
what about
beyond the realms of death
is that a power bill some people want to
say it is
um
[Music]
ah you know
it's hard with a lot of judas priest
songs because they certainly have a lot
of the
elements but
it doesn't completely map onto it but
mark asks what about in trance i would
say in trance
you know well that's a that's a tough
one um i mean it's a song i love to play
and sing
because it does have that like you know
you've got that dynamic contrast between
the verses
um and then the anonym trans you know
comes down really really hard and heavy
um
i guess that's
on the downbeat by the way right that's
right yeah yeah
so and and then as we move into the 80s
right there's i would now i want to fill
this out because i i only came up with
three
bands that i would say are kings of the
power ballad and one of them i think is
a bit iffy
um
one of them is white snake i mean
power ballad after power ballad and they
don't suck you know right they're great
white snake is one of those bands that
kind of straddles the metal light and
the
um
traditional heavy metal thing they're
coming out of the black sabbath d purple
nexus you know they're originally david
coverdale's white snake band and then
they kind of rebrand themselves and they
bring in some pretty amazing musicians
yeah you know
so
um
they're definitely there the scorpions
definitely there as well i mean great
you know album after album without
without pandering in the way that a lot
of bands seem to do or they're like well
we need a power ballad to be the single
to sell to get on mtv the scorpions just
put them out you know
um
well that's a good point yeah
yeah um
motley crue
should they be considered kings of the
power ballad not kings but home sweet
home is a is both
that's definitely a power ballad so
here's a great question then can you
can you be like a superlative power
ballad song
with only one like really really good
power ballad see that's just it because
now i'm i'm trying to think of other
ones motley crew did
that's a lot of
so they have on on uh
later ones
um
without you and you're all i need those
are considered power ballots yeah
um but are they great power balance uh i
mean
i never liked home sweet home i mean we
used to play in the band in high school
to me it was like you know i was like
all about um
i i wasn't into theater of pain neither
was i and i was like they lost me
well that's the thing
i think if they had started out without
shout at the devil and their their
original uh ep
which had a very very distinctive like
ethos and sound they could have like
moved into their post
you know from from uh theater of pain
onward and been okay but it was just
such a glaring
difference i mean think about dawkin for
example right doc and
um
you know they they had sort of a
consistent sound in ethos throughout
their thing they're they're lighter than
say iron maiden or you know just raised
or stuff like that um
motley crue seemed like they were in
that like heavy heavy metal thing with
shout at the devil and then suddenly
they pivot and you're like
yeah and it was interesting because they
suddenly became much much more popular
because they captured
uh
a wider audience through that and it
felt like selling out you know to me
it's really interesting you know like i
don't know
i mean
the
i don't know what we consider the band
extreme
hard rock i don't know but
yeah i don't know if i've ever told you
this but when more than words came out
um
there was like
you know back in the day when you went
to the store if you opened it you owned
it right right
so
so all these you know i don't they
described it as all these mothers went
and bought the album because more than
words was on mtv but of course the rest
of the album is really heavy yeah and so
everybody is trying to return it saying
this is misrepresented and everything
and like nope you opened it you bought
it
and uh even to this day
you know bettencourt like you know it's
kind of like you know if somebody comes
up and wants his autograph he's like
what's your favorite extreme song and if
they say more than words he'll hand the
paper back to you you know wow
that's interesting well he's you know
he's he's filtering out the fans from
the you're fans of one tune are you a
fan of the band
you know and um but warrant has a
similar relationship with cherry pie
you know you've told me that before they
you know
it was it was just a one-off to fill in
some space that needed to be filled in
and it wound up becoming like this
defining song that everybody knew them
for you know
and that wasn't the same album with
uncle tom's cabin
see that was a great song i think that
should have been the big hit yeah
well i mean
what are you gonna do you know the
things capture people's imagination but
i mean is there anybody else i mean if
we're going to think about like
sheer volume i mean i i guess you could
say wasp actually
could be in that you know kings of of
power metal ballads because they have
quite a few believe it or not power
balance right um
i'm trying to here we go sleeping in the
fire
restless gypsy cries in the night those
are just on the early albums and then
they do more later
so
you know they're they could they could
fit in there um
i mean def leppard should fit in there
right
yeah for for two eras the bringing on
the heartbreak
uh era i mean that was a quintessential
80s power ballad
uh and then you know um
hysteria has some on there because
they've discovered the formula then
they're you know
i don't know if they really loved making
that kind of kind of stuff but
it certainly sold you know well
the thing about definitely kept real oh
go ahead loudness yeah i didn't even
think of that um
oh yeah loudness is a great japanese
band probably the most
successful japanese heavy metal band i
would say
so yeah they have some power ballads
aries lament i was you know i forgot to
do the research on this but i also want
to say that the new wave of british
heavy metal band
um oh no i'm suddenly blanking on their
name uh kind of a second-tier band
[Music]
they they they had some some power
ballads they're still around
if i remember them i'll i'll bring it up
later
um
you know judas priest though maybe we
could put them in there too um
and i was actually gonna ask you about
these these songs scott
what do you think so prisoner of your
eyes
definitely a power ballad right off of
the uh
uh it's a b side off of uh screaming for
vengeance
god i don't i can't recall it it's a
b-side where was it released
uh i i don't know because uh i didn't i
didn't get singles back when i was that
age but i i've seen it like on the
deluxe versions of screaming for
you know vengeance i'm missing that but
it starts out soft
uh marx's prisoner of rise is great what
about um
uh the song fever
on screaming for vengeance
it's got that slow backbeat yeah it does
it's it built it starts uh soft uh it
builds to crescendos
it also even has andy and i were joking
about this the sound effect of um
when he says fever you know he's going
to say it's you set my soul on fire but
it's fever
there's like this
exhalation of breath
you know um i mean some of these things
seem a little cheesy now but
i don't know i think that i think that
qualifies as a power ball yeah
yeah i mean
again we need to go the distinction
between the metal power ballad and like
the what yeah we're calling the light
power ballad right there
yeah maybe maybe in in like traditional
heavy metal there's
a different kind of power ballady thing
that's going on you know
yeah i mean because
i guess in this discussion
at this point i would say
the and i don't mean this negatively but
in the glam power ballad there's more
it's there's more of a formula you have
to stick yeah yeah i think with the
metal one there's not so much a formula
because
let's be honest
the formula was the way to sell the
albums like to my mom right right you
know and um
you could write a beautiful song as a
like judas priest
and and uh you don't have to go well
wait a minute mom's not buying judas
priests yeah bob's not buying jews
priests yeah
but it's like you know hold on a second
as soon as she looks at like a big album
back cover with all those guys in
leather and stuff it ain't happening
you know god forbid she finds out that
the lead singer is gay too you know
right exactly
one more judas priesthood before we come
look at those those light metal ones
um
when night comes down off of defenders
of the faith oh well yeah do you think
it's a power ballad i mean i mean a
metal power ballad yeah okay
it has the the you know it's it's coming
in with those guitar synths i think
at the beginning and it's pretty
it's it's
it you can't call it soft but it is slow
you know
well
right the tempo
and it builds
but right but you think of um
uh the the gap between
uh let's call just let's just call a
priest ballad and a in a priest rocker
there's quite a gap there they're not
yeah yeah
yeah you know um
yeah green man alicia is definitely not
a power ballad right
you know
no i mean like i'm thinking of uh
um
breaking the law and stuff like that's
so far from it right yeah
um heading out to the highway you know
let's get started
i'm trying to yeah i'm trying to think
of um
painkiller because that was such a
different album and did so well for them
there's not anything on that right
that would be a power ballad i don't
know
they came back with a message
we're
gonna rock
yeah we're gonna try to be as heavy as
possible
um
well let's talk about some of the
definitely glam ones right so
great white save your love hold on
formulaic right yeah um night rangers
sister christian pro arguably that's
that's a if you had to make like a top
10 power ballad lists that might be in
there oh i agree but a lot of people
were like that don't play that crap
around here if they were like the
heavier heavy metal
um poison and cinderella
you know
i don't know what you got till it's gone
oh i thought nobody's full was the
ultimate power ballad yeah yeah
they and they were you know they were
kind of good at doing that sort of thing
yeah
mark says call back to last month's
episode given how campy power ballads
are reputed to be i'm surprised there
aren't many worthwhile parodies of them
at least none that easily come to mind
steel panther does have a parody they do
have a parody yeah yeah
uh cheesier or it can't be yeah i mean
uh
striper you know who i don't think
anyone would confuse for a heavy heavy
metal band had honestly you know that's
right of course um i mean you're really
going against when you're when you're
like declaring that you're christian
heavy metal in the 1980s you're really
like you know going against the grain
there kicks don't close your eyes and
that was what was that like 1990 that
was like right at the tail
yeah yeah and it was on the radio well
and that's the thing you know the power
balance started to become really really
big like say from 84
and then by the time that you get to 90
that's part of what's surviving into the
early 90s like you know bands like
warrant and slaughter
um i remember i've told scott about this
going to see kiss at alpine valley here
in wisconsin me and my buddy were you
know we're going with with these two
girls and we were there to see kiss and
they were there to see warrant and
slaughter you know
not that they they weren't good and i've
seen slaughter subsequently and enjoyed
them but they really had a reputation of
this is like the bands for for you know
uh the girls because they had the power
ballads and stuff um that's a really
good point
yeah that's a really good point yeah
flight of the angels is a huge
yeah
oh bon jovi you know it was
definitely one of the huge power like um
well especially like you know the
um
the earlier stuff with jon bon jovi was
all about you know we're gonna be the
underdog couple right you know yeah yeah
and you know well they are from jersey
so you are from jersey yeah
but um you know they had a bunch of them
and uh
yeah i mean through
new jersey and
i think they left it more later on
although but like the first few albums
uh is only lonely a powerball valid
that's a great song but i don't know if
it's a ballad yeah
does it have the the requisite elements
we have to ask no i think i think it's
just a um it's a
no it's a it's a it's a rock tune it's a
great pop rock tune
um
i mean talking about like the getting
into the 90s i mean skid row would be
one of the bands that's
putting out power ballads
you know but also doing some hard rock
stuff in life right
like well and i remember you you know oh
god of course
oh this is a really interesting question
from mark do you think part of why power
ballads managed to persist
into the 90s seems uh is because
acoustic guitar seems to gain a new
appreciation in the new decade
i think yeah i think that that is uh the
case that makes a lot of sense
and
um i would say that's part of why we see
the glam
slash light metal bands continuing on
doing that well a lot of the well you
mentioned judas priest painkiller
they're not going to put a power ballot
on painkiller because they're like
trying to they're trying to chart a
different path i mean the 90s made made
us have to sort of like
rethink what counts as heavy metal and
how is this going to survive
being faced with grunge and you know the
rise of much more attention to
alternative and
things like that right so
i mean the um
[Laughter]
i remember the uh it's tesla that
started the acoustic thing right the
five-man acoustic jam
and i guess i mean it's it it's kind of
hard to figure out exactly where it
started right
uh yeah i mean like that's that was the
one that pushed it into popularity
there's another you
yeah i'm i'll i'll attend to that uh
so um
yeah so let's let's uh
let's talk about some of the bands that
are traditional to light right okay yeah
um
so we've got um
white snake we mentioned docking would
be another great example right
oh yeah of course
yep um
uh
well ymt
yt is a great one yeah and they had uh
they had a couple
uh this time don't be afraid of the dark
i mean some of the some of these bands i
think you could say they figured out the
formula right
but they have to be you know it's like
there's a formula but you have to be a
great songwriter to get it right
yeah you know you have to um
you know it's kind of like they say
country is a there's a formula right so
sing about pickup trucks and
you know whatever but um
but there's an art to it you know you
have to be really good at it and so
we'll look at looking at some of the
people that you know on the on any of
the lists that were great songwriters of
yeah and that
also were able to write a good power
ballad
um
with country 2 i mean i think you can
say
country gets really weird too because
you have all these crossovers right
country becomes very pop
to the point where nowadays you're not
even really quite sure other than
lyrical content what counts is it uh yes
you know i noticed we're getting close
to
to time so we probably should talk about
just a few other things i mean we
mentioned some of the traditional heavy
metal bands
twisted sister has some power ballads
the price i think is is arguably one i
believe in you is definitely forgot
about those yeah we forgot about those
queens reich also has i mean silent
lucidity is not a power ballad but i
will remember from the earlier albums
that one is that's a that's a good one
yeah yeah that's from rachel order right
yeah it is yeah and and i you know i
mentioned that there are some in terms
of thrash or speed metal
and so you know metallica nothing else
matters obviously off the black album
clearly one but fade to black is a power
ballad
right well yeah
it gets amazing
well it does get pretty heavy oh well
and it and it does have a a faster
bridge part right
yeah
to the slow tempo
that but yeah it's got a slow slow tempo
at the beginning but it's i don't think
it's a power ballad i think it's uh okay
uh just a form of a metal tube because
you know the old we you know i i would
put that with stairway to heaven where
you've got this beginning and then
you've got this
totally different i don't think that's
uh outro that's like i mean the sick of
patience
yeah you know that's that
that's leaving the then if if you're not
gonna see that one as a power ballad
you're probably not gonna say welcome
home sanitarium would count either then
right
no
i also wouldn't say no one like you by
the scorpions
because it's just got like an
arpeggiated course but
yeah yeah it's no it's fast who do
and it's got that you know like okay
it's the song's introduced with just
like you know shreddy guitar it's great
yeah that that's a rocker
with a with you know a more chill
um but you know like for ozzy goodbye to
romance mama i'm coming home is probably
way
that's dead on
yeah and and this is a good lead-in to
talking really briefly about uh women in
in
metal as well um you know there were
some major female bands and singers so
vixen
i don't know if a lot of people remember
them but they had you know crying edge
of a broken heart lita ford of course
was probably the queen of the power
ballad and and of light metal you know
she has kiss me deadly i mean that even
begins with some like you know really
light
keyboard stuff
yeah if i close my eyes my eyes forever
that's that's right
yeah yeah yeah
um
warlock
you know slash doro um she had to change
the name and there was a whole we talked
about that in the german metal thing
um she did one called for immer you know
uh that's a power ballad and then
there's there's a duet with udo
um
dancing with an angel
but it's interesting because a lot of
the really key
female heavy metal bands
don't do power balance and they're
deliberate about that like girl school
does not do power ballots they're
they're probably the most important
female heavy metal band in the 80s rock
goddess
they don't they do stuff that's kind of
close to power ballads but it's not
power ballads right um acid you know
female fronted not a female band they
they don't do power ballads and we could
go on with the number of others
heart is not really a metal band um but
it's interesting because if you listen
if i think about the people in high
school like who listened to a lot of the
metal light stuff
they were also usually big fans of heart
too
yeah hearts one of those you know
they had something pretty heavy like
barracuda right yeah that's that's right
yeah yeah i mean even magic man is kind
of heavy you know yeah well they when
they made their comeback in 1985 that's
where they got super poppy and glammy
right you know they were kind of like
they were kind of reminding me of like
gypsies playing like post zeppelin stuff
in the 70s you know i i really yeah
they're amazing but when they came out
with the heart reunion album or when
they came back then bad animals and
brigade there's a lot of power ballads
on there but some rockers i mean they
can you know ann wilson's amazing yeah
you know so i you know it's it's hard to
say he's got the pipes this is actually
like a good place to lead into something
else so like if you were into
um
you know
the other lighter bands like bon jovi or
white lion or bands like that you were
probably into heart you were probably
also into some of the other big
power
ballad though not metal power ballad
bands like journey right
sort of that hard rock spectrum you
could say right
you know it's weird now that you're on
journey i don't understand like uh
i always disagree with everything vh1
and mtv labels
yeah well they call it journey the kin
the kings of the ballads and i'm like
are you kidding me have you heard their
you know yes they they've wrote some
great ballads but you know have you
listened to their albums like yeah
that's a fraction of what they do
um
it's weird it's funny how things get
labeled but i don't we don't necessarily
agree with them so it's kind of like
well i always have a good example here
from mark meatloaf yeah another
parameter musician who had a lot of
great balance yeah i mean
oh yeah yeah
yeah i mean these are what we often
would call metal adjacent you know um ac
dc is kind of also in that not not a
power ballad band but you know the sort
of thing that if you're listening to
this you probably also you probably
listen you know that's a good way of
putting it we should have a name for
that because
you know i i in the past said whatever
makes the back of the jacket right yeah
yeah it's like well triumph i think i
think a lot of it was driven by radio
airplay
you know uh you had the hard rock
stations and
they would play a whole variety of stuff
which could include the scorpions might
include dio probably wouldn't include
iron maiden until much later on
and then it would include all this other
stuff like like led zeppelin but also
leonard skynyrd and you know
just sort of like you know i i've
sometimes put it as you know the kind of
stuff that you would you would hear
riding in the back of your dirt bag um
cousin's car
ladies
older cousins he's blaring the radio you
know
that's you know that's a great that's a
that actually should be like a technical
that really brings in the interest
yeah
yeah we you know where i got that idea
from was uh we used to have to carpool
in school
yeah
yeah and so like you'd carpool and it
would be usually moms and dads like
dropping people off but then like this
this one girl that uh went to my school
she was a year older than me and she was
kind of
you know she she was kind of a burnout
let's just say and i was a burnout too
so i'm not i'm not judging her and she
like went out with this guy who was
really really scuzzy but he had like you
know the proverbial [ __ ] and camaro you
know
and
you'd like you know he would be the the
carpool person and so you know he'd sit
in the back and we're driving down the
road and it would always be tuned into
wqfm milwaukee you know and qfn played
this kind of stuff
so
but every once in a while he'd like turn
around you and you'd be like hey man if
you heard this band and he'd pop a tape
in
yeah great yeah yeah that i think we all
have stories like that you know well
yeah it was usually the big brothers are
my friends right yep
or a friend of a friend or a cousin or
something like that yeah but they were
like always dirt bags and you know
not clean and this car smell like
cigarettes or
like
exactly yeah
oh my gosh
well we should we should bring this to a
close um because we're already
way over time um
thanks mark for all the contributions
again happy birthday happy birthday mark
great thanks scott for for joining and
contributing your expertise as usual
that's a great topic i like this one
this is a this was one that we really
had to put on our thinking cap so to
speak yeah yeah it is one of those
things that's that's not clear
at the start although we we think it's
like super clear because there's this
term out there you know so right
hopefully we've provided a little bit of
clarity by the end of this
well you know it's one of those good
discussions that after a while i uh uh i
start thinking more about it and it's
kind of like it usually comes you know
the example used before it's like if
somebody played us something what do you
guys think we would both go yes or no
but then if we articulate why uh
because of this you know
that's the key is being able to explain
it so all right well we're gonna say
goodbye and uh
thanks for for joining us and we'll see
you next time
you